[音楽]
yeah yeah
[拍手]
こんにちは
一木です影響あたりから来ました僕熱海でまちづくりを言っちゃっています
まあ熱海の街がですねー
最盛期からどんどん観光のお客さんが減ってきて僕小さい頃はまだたくさんのお客さん
がいたんですけどどんどんお客さんが減っていって寂しい状況になっていくっても体験
してきました
熱海はですね2子ばっか続きますけど最初あの50年くらい人口が減少し続けています
これか率が45%って言う
街でん
空き家率全国の詩で一番高いって言う
街なんですね20代30代がどんどんの減少していってしまっていて
これ誇らしい筋ですがの出動が県内でワースト1の数字のパレードというそんな街なん
ですね
僕自身はそういう
街で育ってきまして
本当に忘れもしないのがですね2003年の12月なんですけど友人を連れて熱海に
戻った時に
街が廃墟のように真っ暗になっていた姿を目の当たりにしました
でも身近では誰々さん家が夜逃げしたとか自殺したとかですねそんな話ばかりが
たくさん聞こえてきていて
まあそういった光景とかそういったことが未婚率いて離れなかった
だから僕はあたりを何とかしたいなというふうに思って
今から約10年くらい前ですね
地元なために戻ってまちづくりを始めました
てあの
もうあために戻った時に菜食すごくショックだったことが
地元の人たちが一番地元に対してネガティブなんですよ
どっかいいとこないですかって聞かれたら地元の人たちがみんな何もないです
だ
えっちゃんですね
その時に行きたくないなぁと思ったんですよ
でもなんか自分もそう聞かれたらそういうチャーかもしれないって当時思ってですね
またそれでため自分の町のことを知らないからじゃないかなっていうこと思ったんです
ねそれでひたすらいろんなところまちゅある黄色の一つ集めてですね色んな地域の中に
ある面白いね
日ある人たちを探して言ってある日あもうちょい here それをマーチある日私
たりとか
交通
はにしてですね色んなジャンルのものをやってきました
まあこういうことやってきて街はですね結構元気になって活性化してきたんですけど
でも歩けば街は空き店舗店けっていう消去
やっぱりこれもどうにかしたいなぁと思ってですね
5年前
株式会社街森という会社をつくって
街をリノベーションしようと町にですね
沢山の空き物件があるわけですね
あの空き物件停名がてぃぶにを考えられますけれどもでもすぐ使える
安く使える場所がいっぱいあるというふうに読み取ればこういう場所を使って新しい
たちが入ってくればいいんじゃないかということを持ってまずはでも自分たちでやろう
ということで3年間機店舗だったところ
再生してカフェを作ったり
拠点からですねも作り県からで心は昨年ですけど10年間空き店舗だった
元パチンコ屋さんをリノベーションしてゲストハウスマリア宿泊施設を作りました
まあこういうことをやって
まちゅりー
新しいコンテンツを乱していったんですねここはもうあの
結構驚くべきキーところで57年間開いてたっていう場所ですね
そういうところもリノベーションして僕らはコワーキングスペースシェアオフィス
みたいにしてまちづくの仕事をつくっていく場を作っていくということやってる
でこれ通りもですね人が全然あるいけない使われていない
だったらを使ってマルシオやろうということで2ヵ月に1回3年間ってやっつけですね
第こういうことやってくるとですね僕はこういういろんな街のリノベーションの
プロジェクトをやってきたんですけど
やってみるとですね変わらなかったと思っていた街が変わっていくんですね
5年前空き店舗だらけだった通りが変わっていくんです地元の人も5年前はアフグラ
カフェを出すといった時ですねある
この通りのは簡単だが親身なアドバイスで止めと決定
いたんじゃん絶対負けがないから絶対失敗するからやめとけっていうんで
の言われていやいや僕はそんなことないんじゃないですかとが入ってきた
やってきてでキャンパ変わるんですねみんな目線下がっている
そこに新しいことを生み出してきたやってきたですで
まぁ最近そのお肌に
それを言ったらですねそんなこと言ったっけ入ってましたけどね
あのまでもこう変わっていくんですそれだけ意識が変わるんですよ忘れちゃうくらい
っていうふうなことをやっては観光客数も実際に伸びてくるんですこれ僕らだけの
だけじゃないですいろんな街の人たちがやってきたことで街が変わっていくということ
ですね
僕はこれまでまちづくりに人生をかけようと思って10年間取り組んできました
でいろんないいじゃんなこともたくさんありましたし反発されたりですね
いろんなことがありましたでもそれを乗り越えながらやってこれたのは熱海の街を何と
かしたいという地元も何とかしたいということをもありましたけど
もう一つ僕の原体験があるのでこれからその話をしたいと思います
5分ぐらいであのういんどですね
全然関係ない話します
2003年インドこれ部が撮った写真ですへインド行きました
いろいろですね当時縦列10年ちょっと前ですね会がいろいろバックパッカーで旅をし
て歩いてましてインドも1か月くらいて枚パック150円でやるとかいいとまったりし
たんですね本当に貧乏旅行で
そんな所ばっかりに泊まっていけ
der まあこういうあの地元の下で誘われて
今日あの結構式あるからくる母とかって言われてあのいくいくぅとかでンって
まあ村の祭りですね爆竹とかピストになるようなそんなブランド真つ選んでもらって
すごく楽しかったんですよ
花嫁と花婿には一切会わなかったんですけど
そんな楽しい他では得られない体験をしましたでも逆に言うとあの手この大変な体型
申しましてあのこれちょっと読み上げますけどねあのとあるばかものに出会ってあの
今日家に泊まってけって言うから
あじゃあただ止めてくれるのかと思って止まり言ったらですね翌日金払いと100女医
のよ宿に泊まってるぼく2500円原行ってきたんですね
つかめよいまがすごいなぁと思ってこれで曲しちゃったんだからハナ払うの当たり前
だろうっていう日本人金持ちだしてお前金の事しか考えられないのかアンテナ
なんか怒られるって言うことになってですね最初の子その当時スノーだったので
あそうだなぁと思ってやっても払いたくないなぁとか悩んでですね
まあなんか10分ぐらいそういうことを延々と言われ続けてだんだんだんだん腹が立っ
てきてですね
下げるなんてお前が金の事しか考えてないだろうって日本語で言ってあったんですねそ
したら者は勝ったって300円 dt 変換
ブーブー起こったことなんてあまりなかったんですけど
here 自分のこう主張する here till みたいな体型もしてですよね
浦賀港に連れて帰ってヤバイと思ったらですね先ほどを持って話になってよくわかん
ないんですけど
様子が酒飲んだ後にあの前車を呈して酒買って来いと言われてですねインドのあの牛と
かですね
人とへ
猿とかいろんなものがいるグルー道路のな顔で運転させられてあの死ぬかと思って開始
人を殺すかと思ったぐらいなその体験をしたいしたんですけどまぁ何が言いたいかと
いうとですね
こういろんな体験をしてきてあの本当に貧乏旅行してきてですね
まあとにかく何が何でも生き残ってやるってゆーちょが見つけたと思っています
でこういうただですねそういうふうに思って日本に帰ってきたらですねすごいショック
だったのが
都会の人たちのこの死んだような目をした覇気のない閉塞感あふれる
それストレスあふれた酒井ですねそれを感じてすごくショックだったんですよ
まあそういうのもやだなーと思ってまだからたまに後に帰ったり質なんですけど
とはいえやっぱりも東海もそうですけど地方も何かもっと寂れていく指導地の未来ない
なぁと思って
どうしたらいいのかなとなんとかしても自分生き残ってると思ってたんですけどでも
これ自分だけ生き残ってもしょうがないなと
自分だけじゃなくて自分の身の周りの友人とか家族とか
街の風景とか匂いとかそういうものまで全武器残らないと自分にとっては幸せじゃない
なというふうなことを思ってですね
だからさああたりが生き残ってるところそこできるんだということを持ってですねそれ
他8と思った時こういう自分次の世代に含めてやっぱり生き残っていくため
100年後も豊かな暮らしができるまちを熱海でつくるということを自分のミッション
も自分の使命だと思って
そんな事を思い始めたんです
テーマはそれでも深く多いですね異国での様々な体験をしてきました
これまちづくりの話に戻ります
まあこういう場所を作ってきたものですねやっぱりそういう自分の旅の体型もあって
そういう場所に若い人たちや
にも
やって欲しいなと思いましたしこういう場が町にあればおもしろいだろうなぁと思って
これもですね僕らの宿は夢蔵だけで
たびに来た人たちをもてなしするわけじゃないんです町の人たち
街を巻き込みながら街のおじさんたちあの人に会ってくれたの街のことを好きになる
だろうなあみたいなそういう人たちに携わってもらう
水仕掛けをしていますそう
するとこういう姿がですね街を楽しんでいる姿が日常の風景になってくるとマーチって
変わってくるんだなぁと思っています
僕らはこれからさらにですねこのは釈迦の開いている所を泊まれるようにしていきたい
とかどんどんですね街を変えていきたいなというふうに思っています
あの服熱海って言うか部コーチ生まれ育ってたくさんたびにしてくれるんですね人が
それってすごく幸せなことだなぁと思ってで東京からもすぐ通えるような場所
でこういう場所だからこそ僕らはこれからは単純に遊びに行くだけじゃない観光と定住
ないどのたような暮らし方ができるまちをこの熱海で作っていこうというふうに思って
います
あために帰る場所を作ろうとそれだけスタッフも作ってきたんですけど
あのマークをいろいろですねあの言われますけれども
うかやっぱりやってきたことはもっとの自分はもうこのこれをやるんだというですね
それに出会ってしまったがゆえにですねこれであってしまったがゆえに10年前にです
ね
会社勤めしてたんですけど日々熱海のことしか考えられなくなってどうしようもなく
なって仕事が手に付かないので会社を辞めようって思ったんですね
でそういう
街でですねやっぱりまちの未来熱海の街がー
楽しい街になっていくそんな未来も妄想しながらですね
ビジョンってもう総合曲だと思ってるんですけどそういう妄想しながらこの街で
まちづくりに人生をかけてやっていこうというふうに思いました
なんで街ってそもそもじゃあ衰退してきたのかといったらですねみんながですね
自分たちのまちを
自分のことだけしか考えないとか逆にですね
何かに依存してやってきたからです
それが町が衰退してきたり原因です全国各地てー
税金を使ったまちづくりはたくさん送られてきました来てますけどほとんどが失敗して
きています
これからは自分たちの手で稼ぐまちづくりをやっていかなきゃいけないんですね
僕らも全部そういう形で
民間のお金を使いながらへ
まちづくりをやってきましただから民間主導なんですね
民間が先に走るっていうのは大事なことだと思っていますそして何よりも大事なのは
自分たちの暮らしはやっぱり自分たちで作ってくださっ
自分たちの街もやっぱり自分たちで作っていくんですねそれがそういう人が一人でも
増えていくように僕らもそれをやり続けるという
ことをやっていきたいなと思っていますあの子は末造とか2000悩んだら
インドに行こうかなーと思っているのであの若い人にオススメはですね
あのいろいろ悩んだらプレゼントに行けと
いうことが言いたいですねまあいいじゃないといいんですけど旅に行くってやっぱ
すごくいろんな
学びになるので
ぜひ行ってみてくださいでまぁそれでもの選んだでしたやっぱり
熱海に
生きてくださいあざみでお待ちしていますありがとうございました
[拍手]